the Arizona star's new video showing an  explosion at a border agents  gender-reveal party that apparently  sparked the 2017 sawmill wildfire a  target reading boy and girl exploded  with blue smoke before the flames spread  agent Denis Dickey admitted to  accidentally starting this fire that  burned 47 thousand acres in the Santa  Rita Mountains  it caused 8.2 million dollars to put out  the fire  and led to the evacuation of hundreds of  people so you might imagine they are not  happy today what happened to the good  old days the baby would pop out you'd  look down there and say it's a boy it's  a girl or stick to cake that you cut  into inside there blue or pink I mean  they're more that words